Speaker 1: So continuing our candidate interviews
today, we're going to be speaking with Johnny
Teague, who's a Republican running in Texas
seventh Congressional District.
That includes some of the swanky parts of
Houston, Texas, if I understand correctly.
Great.
Great having you on.
I appreciate it.
Speaker 2: It's an honor to be with you.
Thank you, audience for having me.
Speaker 1: So there's a number of different
ways we could start this interview, and this
might be a weird thing, but just as a sort
of gut check, I've been asking a lot of the
different Republican candidates.
We talk to this question and I forgive me
for such a silly question, but who is the
current president of the United States?
Speaker 2: Current president.
United States is a fellow named Joe Biden.
Speaker 1: Okay.
All right.
That's a start.
Is he a legitimate president in the sense
that his election, his presence presidency
represents the will of the voters?
Speaker 2: I think I don't always answer this.
I don't want to be dodgy, but I believe there's
always a question every election going back.
Benjamin Hare Since election, there's always
whoever loses is never fully contented with
the election, but following the electoral
votes and all those other things.
President Biden is our president, just like
President Trump was elected in 2016 or George
Bush in 2000.
Speaker 1: So and if the baseline is that
the loser always has some questions, is there
anything different in 2020 than just the norm
of the loser?
Never really being fully satisfied, as you
say?
Speaker 2: I don't I don't think so.
I think well, I would say there are some differences.
One difference was because of COVID, we had
drive in or drive up voting, which we never
had that before.
So, yeah, there were some differences with
voting this time.
Speaker 1: Okay.
But but big picture, you're not saying it's
a dramatically different situation in terms
of the loser being dissatisfied that they
really lost?
Speaker 2: No.
I mean, 1960 was was a crazy election.
Great questions about it.
Every every election that Hillary Clinton
greatly questions the 2016.
So, yeah, I think you're right.
Speaker 1: All right.
About as reasonable an answer as we've heard,
I guess all all considered.
So.
Okay, in terms of your platform, you know,
one of the things I noticed is that a lot
of your background is heavily religiously
oriented.
I mean, you you know, you're a pastor, you
have a master of divinity, and your religious
credentials are certainly very present when
one reads about your background in terms of
the relationship between religion and civil
government, you you believe that there should
be separation there?
Speaker 2: I believe that there had to be
separation the way our founders intended and
the way the founders intended.
Was it government never, ever interfered with
religion, didn't sponsor a religion.
It didn't favor one religion over another.
That was our founders intent.
But as far as me being a Christian running
for Congress or a pastor, you know, I pay
taxes just like an electrician does, just
like a rancher does, and I'm a rancher.
And when our when our founders said it should
be a government, it really coming back to
link and a government of the people.
For the people, by the people.
I'm part of the people.
And is I pay taxes is that I'm able to vote.
A pastor ought to be able to run for office
just like electrician or publisher or a lawyer.
Speaker 1: Absolutely.
Now, when you think about your views on any
particular issue, and this is really a very
broad philosophical question, you, of course,
can't separate your religion from your opinions.
And so for many folks, their opinion about
something like abortion personally is informed
by their religion, which is part of their
moral code, without question that that, I
think, is the case for everybody.
Do you believe that those religious views
alone are enough to determine what should
be law in the United States?
Speaker 2: Well, let me come back.
You use the term religion.
Let me use a different term world view.
Not everybody has a religion.
Right and type of religion.
There are some who just are agnostic.
Speaker 1: Yeah, you could be absent a religion.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
So?
So world view is what we're talking about,
not religion.
My worldview is it's shaped by my faith, no
doubt.
But just like someone else's worldview is
shaped by their lack of faith.
We all have backgrounds and experiences, but
yeah, I mean, my my sense, my belief I didn't
run is based on two things God's word and
the Constitution, no different from John Adams,
who said Our form of government is only for
moral and religious people, it's not adequate
for any other.
So I kind of hold that same view that.
John Adams Yeah.
Speaker 1: Your, your Twitter account is really
interesting now, I guess I should say.
But do you do you run your own Twitter account
or is someone else.
Speaker 2: Oh, I doubt that Twitter thing.
I, I guess I guess President Trump was a big
Twitter fella.
I'm not a Twitter guy.
I have a little lady that puts things out
there who volunteered for the campaign.
And so I really tried to rein that in because
it's so quick.
Whoever runs your Twitter account, they almost
take on the personality of the candidate when
they're not the can.
Speaker 1: The reason I'm glad you're telling
me that, because I don't even know if you
know this.
But on your Twitter account, there's a lot
of Q and on stuff.
Now, just like as a as you have you ever heard
the term QAnon before.
Speaker 2: I have it in.
When you say there's a lot of Q and on I know
in 2020 the lady who did my Twitter thing
put out a Q and nine.
There was something the Q and I put out that
she liked and shared it.
I guess that's what you do with Twitter.
And man, I started getting all kinds of calls.
Are you with Q and I?
Do you support Q anon?
And I'm like, No, I don't.
At that time I know who they were.
And so I'm praying.
You've only seen one thing on Q and I will.
Speaker 1: I've seen four, you know, so, so
I mean, just glancing through, I saw a retweet
of three women taking what's called the Q
and on oath I saw a retweeted video with a
JFK Junior Conspiracy theory, which is a big
Q and on thing I saw.
Speaker 2: Was that brother.
Speaker 1: I'm sorry.
Speaker 2: Do you remember the dating.
Speaker 1: On it says June.
Although I admit it's not clear whether it's
June of this year or last year.
Speaker 2: Well, I tell you what, and I'm
not trying to be evasive by any means.
You can look at my post on Facebook, you can
look at my post on my website.
You'll never see a dog thing on Q and on.
But if what you're saying is correct and when
we finish, I will make sure I do check that
fair that well, I'll shut the Twitter account
down.
Okay.
Speaker 1: But so you seem to be clear, like
you, you have nothing positive to say about
Q and on and you're not associated in any
way with that?
Speaker 2: I'm not associated at all.
And I thought we would take care of this in
2020.
We have a sweet lady named Miss Eileen and
Miss Lane.
You know, I'm I'm a guy just running.
I have about 300 volunteers to work with me.
Nobody's paid.
And so just like a pastor, my church, I trust
people to do what I expect them to do.
And when they don't, I have to take some pretty
strong action.
They go, so I would shut that puppy down outside
any Q and non stop and you can check me in
2 hours.
Beautiful.
If there's anything there, it will be gone
or the Twitter cannot be closed.
Speaker 1: Okay, fair let's let's dig into
something policy oriented just to give our
audience a sense of where you are taxes.
Okay.
To pick something that is often a hot button
issue right now in terms of the federal income
tax brackets and rates that we have.
What's your opinion to high to low?
Just right.
Not enough brackets.
Too many brackets.
Speaker 2: Well, I think we're probably okay
right now with the tax structure.
I don't like that we're $33,000,000,000,032
trillion in debt.
I know that we've just hired our we've set
the bill for 87,000 new IRS agents.
What I'm finding is we are spending way too
much in government.
And when you spend way too much in government,
you've got to try to pay for that somehow.
So what we do is raise taxes.
And I believe our government has got to spend
less and tax less, especially when when I
look at, you know, everybody should pay their
fair share and everybody ought to pay their
taxes without cheating.
Yes.
I believe that we you know, I drive on those
roads that the tax is paid for.
I take advantage of the police department
in their protection that those taxes paid
for.
So as a Christian, as a pastor, as a citizen
of the United States, I believe we pay what
our taxes are.
We don't look for a way out of it.
And that's a problem with people in Congress,
I'm afraid.
And that's why I'm for term limits.
Eight years.
Get the heck out.
Serve the people and don't be financially
rewarded for the time you serve the kids.
And that removes the whole word of service.
But we find a lot of people in Congress, the
very ones who are raising taxes and hiring
IRS agents are the ones who pay so few taxes.
And so I honestly think every tax return ought
to be made public if you're in public office,
if you're elected that way, you see people
are living under the very laws you're making
everybody else.
But a short answer to your question, forgive
me for going long.
Short answer your question.
I think it's probably okay the way it's set
up, as long as taxes aren't continually being
raised, as long as we're not finding other
ways to raise more money to cover overspending.
Speaker 1: So to just go back to the IRS agents
thing, I couldn't tell from when you mentioned
the hiring of additional IRS agents, whether
you see that as a good thing or a bad thing,
because it seems as though being so short
staffed, those additional IRS agents will
actually bring in more money by by finding
people who are cheating than what they cost
from the analysis I've seen.
So are you are you in favor or against the
additional entry?
Speaker 2: Good.
Speaker 1: Or you're against it.
Speaker 2: And I think when you look at what
we're paying for 87,000 next year, we're not
short staffed.
You know, we need to make sure that we're
well staffed.
But 87,000 agents, you look at the cost for
those 87,000 agents.
And then you've got to do the math and figure
out will they really pay for themselves?
And if they just pay for themselves, that's
not a benefit at all.
Speaker 1: No, that's true.
But I guess I would question like the Congressional
Budget Office, nonpartisan does scoring of
all of these proposals, they found that it
actually would bring in more revenue than
than than it would cost.
Do you have something to contradict that?
Speaker 2: Well, no, I don't, because, again,
I'm not in Congress, so I don't get special
insights into how they formulated.
Speaker 1: No, neither am I.
But I'm just saying, is there anything we
both have access to?
All the same things?
Do you have anything that would point in a
different direction?
Speaker 2: I don't.
I mean, I'm a mathematician through training,
but I'd have to look at it.
But I honestly believe that we don't need
87,000 IRS agents.
And I honestly believe that we can we can
be a lot more frugal in what we do.
And again, we should never cheat on our taxes.
We should pay our taxes in full.
In the same light, though, we need to not
spend beyond what we have.
Our our national debt is a clip show GDP.
Right.
It's just not right.
You know, Johnny Teague, in my world, I don't
make a lot of money, but I can't spend more
than I make.
And we have got to apply that.
I think government should spend less so we
tax less.
I think we should not give out as much money
but as people to earn their living.
And so I just really believe and I'll give
you an example, we just spent, I think, $11
million here in Houston to beautify our bus
stops.
Now, I just think it's great to beautify bus
stop.
Sure.
$11 million.
And let me give you a quick example.
My people are campaigning for me.
They put out my cards throughout the community.
I want one guy, which I hate.
I tell him, don't put these cards on a car
that irritate people.
It hacks them off.
Don't kill the car.
But one guy put in a lady's windshield.
Well, it rained here in Houston, and that
lady tried to pull.
Went off for windshield after the rain in
the paper stuck to the windshield.
So she called me and she said, Johnny, I'm
going to vote for you.
You have said in your statements, you think
we are to love, care for others, and do right.
I'm going to see if you're going to back that
up.
My windshield.
I can't get the paper off my windshield.
I want you to come to my house this afternoon,
wash my car.
I said, ma'am, I'm so sorry about the happening.
If I was free, I'd come watch it.
But I'll tell you what.
Please go get it washed and I'll pay for the
watch.
I promise.
So she called me yesterday and says, Johnny,
I got the car wash.
It looks wonderful.
I go, Great.
She is.
Now, I got to tell you, I'm not able really
to drive.
It was actually in her in her front yard.
She goes, So I had to order one of those mobile
car wash companies to come to my house and
wash my car.
I said, Well, I know those are kind of expensive.
How much did it cost?
She said, It was $210.
Yeah, well, Johnny had to pay $210 to get
a little paper up the windshield.
And I ask you the question, why do you think
she was willing to pay $210?
Speaker 1: Well, because it was Johnny Teague's
money.
No, I understand.
But some of these analogies, I mean, you know,
you analogized to you can't spend more than
you have.
So.
So but countries regularly deficit spend.
I don't think deficit spending is necessarily
the issue.
I mean, give me a sense of what would you
cut?
What do you cut from the federal budget?
Speaker 2: Well, honestly, I'd cut I cut some
of the departments.
I would cut some of the excessive things that
we do.
Which which ones?
Huh?
Speaker 1: Which ones?
Speaker 2: Which what?
Speaker 1: Which departments and which excessive
things that we do.
Speaker 2: Which departments?
I honestly would probably cut the Department
of Education.
Not surprisingly, cut the Environmental Protection
Agency.
I would probably cut the Federal Reserve.
Now, again, I'm coming to you again as an
outsider.
So please know I don't have full knowledge
of of anything.
Yeah, like based, you know, just like you
may not have full knowledge on how I raise
my black angus cattle.
You probably don't know what I have to do
to have my coast or grow my hate filled.
I don't think a lot of the congressmen would
know that because I do that every day.
Yeah, well, I'm going to come at you, not
be in the know at all.
That's good to hear, to learn from you, bro.
Speaker 1: Well, I would propose, Johnny,
that on Department of Education, eliminating
Department of Education has become a popular
right wing idea to damage public schools under
the premise that they are liberal indoctrination
to instead support religious and so-called
patriotic education.
I don't like it.
I think I think it's a Trojan horse.
And the truth is that if you eliminate the
Department of the EPA, this idea that every
business is incentivized to police itself
when it comes to pollution, it's been proven
false and without the EPA pollution and as
a result, all sorts of disease and cancer
as a result of that pollution would explode.
Those are the perspectives I would encourage
you to consider.
Speaker 2: Well, and I actually disagree with
you, and I think I'm not surprised.
And I mean I mean, we can go with what you
say or if you want me to share, I'll be happy
to.
Speaker 1: No, I mean, I'm just suggesting
you consider those perspectives.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
And may I say, I don't believe that.
One aim to change our Department of Education
or believe it isn't some right wing Christian
or our biblical pounding thing.
You look at how kids are doing right now in
math, for instance, and I taught college algebra.
They're doing terrible in math.
Look at how they're achieving on these different
metrics where the science or English kick
the can even right cursive anymore, where
we have seen that writing cursive forms the
connection, the brain and the memory better
than just printing.
So, I mean, these are just basic things.
I think we're we're teaching kids the French
things, which I think are fine.
But I think we've got to get back to the basics.
And so I believe we need to spend more time
teaching math, science, English, things that
are really going to help kids function in
life and get a job at or after they get out
of school.
Now, with the EPA, I believe firmly you're
right.
I think there have been great errors in the
past, great crimes against humanity at times
that have really harmed people.
We see it even here in Houston, where companies
sometimes more worried about the bottom line
than anything.
But today, in a social conscious, in a social
media and a moment by moment news cycle, I
believe there's greater policing.
I mean, there's a reason why oil and gas companies
are looking at wind and solar and they're
looking at cleaning the environment.
You see BlackRock and these other investors
that are that are really pressing them.
And I'm not a BlackRock fan, but they're pressuring
these companies to be more socially responsible.
So you look at oil and gas right now, people
are complaining about the price of gas and
I'm one of them.
You look at what our government said and again,
you're going to disagree.
But I believe that our government has cut
drilling.
I believe our government has cut pipelines.
I believe our government has made it hard
to have a refinery.
And even I talked to an oil executive the
other day, and I was an accountant for shale.
So I do have some oil and gas experience.
You may say it's jaded.
But in oil and gas, guys say journey.
It's more risky or it's as risky.
Let me be accurate.
It's as risky for us to drill in the United
States as it is Venezuela or Nigeria.
And that's because they spend all this money
in R&D.
They go to, well, ready to come, and then
the government yanks that license or that
permit and sometimes under the guise of protecting
some species.
And yet you look at wind and solar and the
damage it does to species as well.
I think we've got to care for our environment.
But anyway, I think that regulations are raising
prices.
I think they're harmonious.
I'm a farmer, a race.
Hey, fertilizer is three times more this year
than it was last year.
And I know part of that's the Russian invasion
of Ukraine, but we're also being told what
fertilizer we can use, what we shouldn't use,
and now we're telling food shortages are going
to occur.
So I just think that we've got government
does a good job, but yeah.
Overreach just like I.
Speaker 1: Well, if I may, Johnny, that was
the equivalent of an inkblot of different
things going between fertilizer prices, wind
power species.
And I don't think it will shock you that I
disagree with basically everything you just
said, but that's going to have to be for a
different conversation.
Since we have a we, our time today has elapsed.
It's an interesting race that you're running
in the seventh Congressional District.
We've been speaking with Republican Johnny
Teague.
Let's see how things go in November and then
we'll will reconvene from there.
Speaker 2: And let me say one thing.
Yeah, I'm thankful for you and I'm thankful
that we disagree.
Thank you.
And I do want to list and David, I'm not always
right.
In fact, I'm often wrong.
True.
But I do want to learn and thank you for being
so gracious to me.
Regardless of where you stand on the issues.
I'm thankful we live in a country where we
can be free and we can still be brothers and
Americans and have vast differences on the
issues.
Speaker 1: I appreciate your time.
Thank you.